jean marc bonjour alors on savait que la
crise sanitaire et son impact sur
l'économie creuse les inégalités entre
les riches et les pauvres
l'arrivée de l'hiver la perspective d'un
nouveau confinement risque d'aggraver la
situation alors deux questions que va
faire le gouvernement et cela sera-t-il
suffisant pour juguler cette nouvelle
pauvreté selon vous vous savez dans
l'immédiat le gouvernement il essaie de
répondre à toutes les demandes et les
besoins les plus urgents et on voit bien
qu'il a du mal parce que le virus
commence à faire de sérieux dégâts sur
le fond sanitaire vous le disiez et sur
le front économique cette crise comme
toutes les crises graves accroît les
inégalités entre les riches et les
pauvres entre ceux qui vont pouvoir
d'ailleurs gardé leur leur travail ou
qui bénéficient encore de l'allocation
chômage partiel et ceux qui vont perdre
leur job et voir leurs revenus fondre et
disparaître alors ce week-end c'est vrai
le premier ministre s'est adressé aux
plus précaires ont leur permettre de
surmonter un peu le choc deux priorités
la première priorité c'est de favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle c'est-à-dire
essayer de conserver le maximum
d'emplois
et puis aussi en trouver pour ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas ou ceux qui l'ont perdue
ou ceux qui arrivent en fin de droit et
qui n'ont même pas le recours de faire
un peu de travail au noir donc cela va
passer principalement par des créations
d'emploi pour faciliter l'accompagnement
des personnes qui sont les plus éloignés
de l'emploi pour pas qu'ils décrochent
complètement alors ça représente environ
30000 emplois d'insertion
professionnelle qui vont être créées
pour des contrats dead avec une prime en
plus exceptionnelle de 150 euros plus
100 euros par enfant pour ceux qui sont
éligibles à ce type de primes
deuxième priorité c'est faciliter
l'accès au logement pourquoi bien vous
le disiez parce que l'hiver arrive
il ne faudrait pas qu'on ajoute une
crise de logement et de sans abri à la
crise sanitaire donc l'administration va
redynamiser l'aide pour éviter les
impayés pour essayer de trouver des
solutions à ceux qui ne peuvent plus
payer les droits y est et dégagé sur
tout des places d'hébergement et
d'accompagnement social
les associations
pas convaincus de l'efficacité d'un tel
dispositif jean-marc non parce que les
associations et actions sur le terrain
elle voit la misère progresser de jour
en jour et les associations s'occupent
de la grande pauvreté et les
associations auraient préféré parce que
pour elle c'était plus simple et peut
être plus efficace une augmentation des
prestations une augmentation des fameux
minima sociaux une augmentation du rsa
par exemple ou même de la location en
fin de droits se dire sceptre on touche
lorsqu'on n'a plus les droits au chômage
c'est leur ligne de défense plastique
qui revient à privilégier l'assistance
alors le premier ministre ne va pas sur
ce terrain il assume son choix de
renforcer les aides exceptionnelles
plutôt que de majorer le système social
en vigueur
parce qu'il considère que la situation
est exceptionnelle parce qu'ils espèrent
qu'elle est provisoire et parce que son
objectif premier c'est je le répète de
protéger la machine économique
l'entreprise des emplois et enfin parce
que le système social est en cours de
réforme
alors la crise sanitaire a tout stoppé
tout paralyser on va d'ailleurs le voir
aujourd'hui puisque le gouvernement
reçoit la plupart des syndicats pour
reparler de tous ces dossiers chômage
retraite prestations sociales
mais pour l'instant le gouvernement ne
va pas réouvrir ses dossiers il ne veut
pas rajouter de la complexité à la casse
qui est déjà compliquée il essaie de
répondre aux urgences et l'urgence des
urgences
eh bien ce sont les emplois l'économique
et le logement
mais après tout les plus fortes porte
sur la modestie de ce que ces mesures
représentent dans le plan de relance
oui parce que si on compare ce qu'elle
représente par rapport à l'ensemble du
plan de relance
c'est vrai qu'elles peuvent paraître
modestes le plan de relance je vous
rappelle ces 100 milliards d'euros il a
pour ambition de faire redémarrer
l'économie
il est applicable au 1er janvier et il
est année sur deux ans qui comprend des
investissements pour les entreprises
environ pour 80 milliards c'est à dire
la relocalisation industrielle
transition énergétique
et puis du digital aussi et puis il ya
20 milliards pour des mesures
d'accompagnement social emploi formation
alors les mesures
tu es l'annoncé ce week-end eh bien elle
représente d'euros 700 millions mais
elles sont applicables avant la fin de
l'année moitié pour insertion
professionnelle je vous le disais puis
moitié pour le logement
quand on regarde globalement un ce que
font les pays européens sur le plan
social bien on est quand même dans la
moyenne haute
dans les pays anglo saxons dans la
grande bretagne si on regarde aux etats
unis c'est encore pire les classes
pauvres ils sont beaucoup plus
vulnérables et sont beaucoup plus en
risque elles sont touchées beaucoup plus
directement encore par la crise du
comice notre problème en france c'est de
maintenir l'emploi
notre problème en france c'est de
maintenir des entreprises debout
d'où le débat d'ailleurs actuellement
entre le degré de compliments qu'il
faudrait accepter pour pouvoir ralentir
le coc vite sans pour autant asphyxier
l'économie
maintenant tout ça dépend de combien de
temps ça va la pandémie va durer tout
dépend combien de temps aussi l'opinion
va supporter les mesures de protection
sanitaire et de restrictions d'activités
qui sont mises en place pour ralentir ce
fieffé de se fier tuer les virus
si beaucoup jean marc silva ce d'avoir
répondu à nos questions